um let's see I mean okay that the person
who's been holding the longest now is
Jimmy from Philly and I know the
audience is very mixed about hearing
from him but let's just give him a
chance and see what he what he has to
say today David yes Jimmy yeah David I
don't understand this with the whole
mower thing you're claiming that moment
has all this evidence of obstruction and
yet I'm not claiming Mulder claims no
charges per 12 what do we what did they
hire this guy for you got all this
evidence that he punched at the bar it's
ridiculous it's it's political force and
you don't think you think that Moeller
should have charged Trump you're saying
um if there was evidence yes well there
was why he didn't charge him it's
political book that's why I punted them
more to keep this book our Jimmy plea
please don't smart cuz we got to go in
and bleep on every single bed yeah so do
you not believe the evidence that's in
the Moller report or did you not look at
it there there is no evidence David he's
allowed to fire what's his name marler
he's allowed to fire co me you know that
if you look at the Muller report Muller
says that actually the firing of Comey
met all three of the requirements to be
an obstructive act as defined by the law
no he has the constitutional authority
to fire him or how do you know how do I
know more than Mulder Jimmy are you
aren't you a landscaper what Jeff
alright now I know what isn't your
expertise and landscaping not law or are
you an economist did you go to school
for economy I did yeah okay and you're
commenting on political stuff Authority
Jimmy the difference is I'm deferring to
the legal experts you're saying that the
illegal experts are wrong yeah I would
say so I would say it's all political
David I'm really worried about your
drinking and I would really I would
encourage you I don't know if you're
going to meetings currently but it would
really mean a lot to me if you started
taking this issue seriously and going
meetings and people write in and they
say David I'm in treatment Jimmy is in a
rough place please encourage him to seek
treatment so I'm asking you to do that
Jimmy David I don't drink as much as you
think I do I only think you drink as
much as you tell me and it's a lot I
told you two nights a week no you didn't
what that is what I told you but listen
to this I did a little LSD two weeks ago
and that helped me with drinking so how
old a guy are you Jimmy how old do you
think I am I was imagining you as 55 55
yeah 56 okay well there you go
Jimmy all right so I'm worried about you
I'm worried about you I hope that you
will get you'll get the help that you
need
always Bob I'm doing fine David very
good all right Jimmy thank you very much